今天要聊一個很有趣的創業故事。你有沒有想過，安撫嬰兒這件事，也能變成一門年營收五百萬美元的生意？
喔？安撫嬰兒？這聽起來很日常啊。市面上不是已經有很多奶嘴跟安撫產品了嗎？這種傳統市場還能怎麼做出「新」意？我第一時間會覺得競爭太激烈了。
這就是有趣的地方。這對姊妹一開始也沒這麼順利。她們是Jane Molina和Joy Williams，一開始其實在經營家裡的冷暖氣公司。你猜怎麼著，因為媽媽發現兒子吸奶只是為了尋求安撫，但又找不到能模擬真實乳房、鼓勵寬口含乳的奶嘴，所以才想自己做。
嗯，這確實是很多媽媽會遇到的狀況。但從一個個人痛點，到成立公司、做出產品，中間要跨過的門檻可不少。而且，她們本來家裡的公司經營得怎麼樣？會不會是原本的事業不順才轉去做這個？
你說到重點了。原文有提到，她們的家族企業在2008年金融危機後其實很掙扎。Joy Williams甚至說過：「我們基本上鞋底都穿破了，吃著義式香腸三明治，喝可樂，發完薪水帳戶裡只剩150美元。」這種情況下要再開一個新事業，確實是出乎意料的決定。
這樣聽起來，她們的資源應該很有限。那她們具體怎麼把這個想法變成產品，甚至上市銷售的？從「吃香腸三明治」到「五百萬美元營收」，中間肯定有不少轉折。
她們真的蠻拚的。一開始大概七年，都是利用閒暇時間在做Ninni Co.這個品牌，名稱是紀念她們祖母的。她們甚至動用到退休金和個人儲蓄去開發原型，成本不到一千美元，還請律師申請了專利。
等等，七年才推出產品？這時間線也拉太長了吧。一般創業公司可能撐不到這麼久。這段期間她們的資金是怎麼撐下去的？除了動用退休金，還有沒有其他管道？
有的。2019年她們決定孤注一擲，把家裡的冷暖氣公司賣掉，得到50萬美元，雖然大部分都拿去還債了，但確實為Ninni Co.提供了第一筆大資金。後來也參加了孵化器計畫，還得到了一筆1萬美元的贊助。
所以她們是先有技術、有原型，才開始募資和找生產商。那這個奶嘴的關鍵點在哪？為什麼會比市面上現有的產品更有吸引力？不然如果產品本身沒差異化，光靠行銷是很難持續的。
關鍵就在於它的設計。這個奶嘴模仿的是真實乳房組織，能鼓勵嬰兒寬口含乳，這對很多媽媽來說是一個沒被滿足的需求。而且她們找的製造商就在紐約州北部，可以確保品質。
但光有好的產品，沒有人知道還是白搭。所以她們是怎麼讓這款奶嘴爆紅的？我猜啦，應該是跟社群媒體有關？
沒錯，就是社群媒體！2021年3月她們在Shopify上線，一開始銷量平平，甚至有時候一天零銷售。但到了4月，她們朋友，也是個網紅，在Instagram上分享了使用心得，Joy Williams再把這支影片轉發到TikTok。
然後就爆紅了？所以是病毒式行銷的力量。那這算是可遇不可求吧？對一般創業者來說，找網紅發文也不是這麼容易就成功的，成本也不低。
其實這點就是可學習的地方。她們很早就開啟了Shopify的手機通知，追蹤每一筆訂單。當晚她們手機的「叮咚」聲就沒停過，隔天醒來才發現Ninni Co.真的爆紅了。這不是單純靠運氣，她們前期投入在產品開發和專利保護的努力，是讓產品有機會被看見的基礎。
嗯，所以說，一個看似不起眼的需求，透過獨特的產品設計解決痛點，再搭配成功的社群媒體策略，才有了後來的成功。那對於我們這些一般上班族，這個案例有什麼啟發嗎？總不能叫我們都去創業吧。
我覺得是提醒我們，在日常工作中，可以試著從「小」地方去觀察，有沒有什麼習以為常，但其實可以改善、優化的環節。就像她們，從一個簡單的「安撫」需求，看到市場空缺，進而創造價值。這不一定是要開公司，也可以是把一個小專案做得更貼近使用者，做出超乎預期的成果。
這倒是。確實很多時候，我們容易忽略那些看似「理所當然」的事情，反而覺得要搞大計畫才有價值。這個案例告訴我們，或許從小地方著手，把一個很小的問題解決到極致，也能創造出意想不到的巨大價值。
就像這個Ninni Co.，一開始連五萬、七萬美元的模具費都拿不出來，要靠銀行貸款、天使投資才撐下來。但最終卻能做到年營收530萬美元。好像也提醒了我們，只要目標夠明確，肯花時間投入，很多事情都有可能。